Schmigadoon
Schmigadoon is a story of a couple who are
having some issues and challenges in their relationship.
They cross the bridge. And they're lost in a town that is an old movie musical.
As long as they have a functioning toilet I’m in.
The town is in an alternate universe.
The town is a musical, and now they're stuck in that musical.
Why is music coming from everywhere?
♪ Schmig-a-doon where the sun... ♪
The people in Schmigadoon don't sort of realize they're unusual.
They don't realize they're singing either, which is hilarious.
That was a very handsome song.
What song?
Schmigadoon is colorful and fun. Everything is sung.
You know how much I hate musicals.
People don't just burst into song in real life.
And then of course, as we get to
pull the layers back a little bit, you get to see that it's not so perfect
as it might look from the outset.
The whole thing is supposed to feel so surreal.
There's this beautiful mix
of present day reality and very much an old world sensibility.
It is we! The mothers against the future.
So you're against the passage of time?
It’s a star-studded cast
that's so good at musical theater,
and really bringing all that Broadway experience has been amazing.
It was a dazzling cast
on top of Cinco’s great creativity and Barry Sonnenfeld’s vision.
What I liked about Cinco’s scripts were A, they were very funny
and B, Cinco has written fantastic songs.
♪ It’s only a lover’s spat. ♪
♪ First she says ♪
So what's the plan, Josh? Look for someone new?
♪ Then he says ♪
I’m not having a discussion that's part of a musical number
We're all so fortunate that Barry Sonnenfeld was
the person who signed on to direct us.
And it's so stylized and beautiful, but at the same time, we are still
telling a funny and emotionally grounded story.
Oh, you're not going to want to drink that, Missy.
That there's the gentleman's Punchbowl.
It's got alcohol in it.
Oh, thank you for the warning Larry, the fireman.
We are giving a love letter to music theater.
You are going to laugh your butt off,
and you also might shed a tear.
The characters are wonderful and the songs are wonderful and the sets are beautiful.
The acting is perfection.
It’s just different than what you're used to seeing on TV.
You're going to be watching something magical for these six episodes.
Do you think this is true love?
There’s so much to enjoy.
You're sitting down and smiling the whole time.
Sold!
♪ And we call it Schmiga…. Schmigadoon ♪
Wooo...Wooo hooo.
Yay!
You guys did that.
Can we please go now?